bueno se está sosteniendo mucho este
incremento de casos mencionabas recién
el número de muertes por millón de
habitantes y algo crucial la presión
sobre el sistema de salud y las cámaras
de terapia intensiva en algunos lugares
del país hay decenas de personas que
están esperando un lugar en camas de
terapia y no lo consiguen esto es muy
preocupante para el gobierno nacional y
también para los gobiernos provinciales
y al menos hasta hace un rato estaba
reunido el presidente alberto fernández
con gobernadores en una reunión virtual
tras haberse reunido con especialistas
para ver qué medidas se pueden
implementar cuáles pueden ser bueno se
está barajando y se está diciendo que
una de las medidas importantes que se
puede llegar a implementar es este fin
de semana un cierre total en lo que es
el área metropolitana de buenos aires la
ciudad de buenos aires y sus alrededores
que es donde vive un porcentaje más alto
de la población argentina y donde hay
mucha circulación viral y otra
posibilidad que se está barajando es que
la ciudad de buenos aires- que se había
resistido una decisión de nación de
cerrar la presencialidad escolar está
empezando a alejar la posibilidad de al
menos en algunos niveles escolares
por suspendida al menos temporalmente la
presencialidad por ejemplo en el nivel
secundario esto es lo que estamos
esperando que anuncien tal vez en las
próximas horas o el próximo día el
presidente al órgano fernando por otra
parte natalio del gobierno implementó
restricciones a la exportación de carne
durante 30 días en respuesta el sector
decidió parar la actividad por nueve
días porque esta decisión oficial y que
puede pasar ahora
el principal argumento del gobierno es
que el incremento sostenido en los
precios de la carne no es algo que esté
ayudando en este contexto especialmente
a la población y el argumento entonces
es que al frenar las exportaciones van a
conseguir que haya mayor oferta de carne
en el mercado local y por lo tanto se
contenga el precio de los precios de la
carne según un estudio del instituto de
promoción de la carne vacuna argentina
fue del 65,3 por ciento del último año
un incremento muy por encima de la
inflación general y esto lo que preocupa
el gobierno por el argumento del sector
de la carne es que no será así y que en
el pasado como cuando hubo restricciones
como la de este tipo terminó impactando
negativamente no sólo en el precio que
también aumentó progresivamente sino que
al quedar las exportaciones cayó el
ingreso de divisas un ingreso de divisas
crucial para el país la carne hoy en día
representa más o menos entre el 4 y el 5
por ciento del total de los dólares que
entran en la argentina por las
principales exportaciones del país